louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
[Applause]
shut down his channel you have a problem
with that not gay Johnny goes insane no
notifications
oh it's with the leg
[Applause]
two points there so yeah Lawrence
nothing ready
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
finish him
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
monetizing here in the morning
what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is called authentic African dance
cuz I watch black panther I think that's
how they did it get your spirit party I
finally watched Black Panther this week
for those who are not mug Club members
and I thought it was so laughably bad at
Parts I understand why some people liked
it but I'm sitting there Washington Hall
second here is a lady in traditional
African garb with a spear on a Tesla
come on and I am upset that I had
friends recommend this to me alright we
have a fantastic show today we have mr.
brexit Nigel Farraj in the show boom yes
we have Owen Benjamin the show we have
Lauren southerners show of course the
premiere people just saw a continuation
of a club kid it'll be really good gonna
be a really good show and next next week
we have Ralph Macchio the real Ralph
Macchio on the show yeah Roth machi next
week in the show it's gonna be you're
not invited working for what else I mean
your seat my hard times and we can talk
about by the question the day before we
get in policy-wise those who thought
President Donald Trump would be a
disaster I had a bit of a wait and see
attitude but I will admit policy was I
think I was wrong I think the last week
I've been pretty damn good to taxes so I
want to know at what point do you admit
that you're or do you say that you're
wrong or what you think about President
Trump at this point comment below also
we're coming up on to mine subscribers
pretty soon so tell us how long you been
watching listening what it is that you'd
like to see more less who knows
presumably in videos to do as always is
dear to his neck a foeman knock cage
area to meet his creditor as long as
we're not banned with your photo shops
your comments your videos a mural
you're always good yes but speaking of
things you need less stuff I'm going to
be on the top of the list I can
guarantee you my naked ass it's going to
me my shekel is from the Illuminati Jew
meeting my naked ass and then my face
that order necessary fulfill my
obligations alright you didn't let me
finish the statement normally unbound
driving conclusions and at G Morgan Jr
he's just he's a sommelier for those who
don't know he's gonna be going you were
telling the other day it's actually
really hard to become hard isn't it I'm
gonna be ready with overlays Wow
hold on I'll go back to you what's the
wine of the day Jill have
double-back Cabernet oh that's right it
just happens to be not a Jared zero
favorite wine we got drunk on a boat
that he could not afford it apparently
post-show there's a little bit of a
shindig celebration and this is actually
your gift bottle from Stevens true this
is going that's true yeah so it's a nice
break for those who don't know Brokeback
these expensive chapstick is he'll be
selling it for crack very soon don't
worry I'm sorry meth meth meth we have
to get the racial stereotypes right with
you later I'm ready with overlays I have
a big announcement regarding my social
media and that is that I
oh yeah that's healthy and I mean you
can check if it's still there and if you
check it by the way today we're gonna be
getting a lot of people asked after the
Venezuela video with John Oliver the
rebuttal
daepung is sort of myth of the Nordic
socialist are successful so we're gonna
do that today I'm gonna get into that
because we'll be talking about news with
Nigel and Lauren and Owen so look into
that Evergreen segment there but there's
other news of the day a new
whistleblower now claims that Steve
Bannon allegedly used personal data to
try and suppress the black vote this is
a quote from CNN says mr. Bannon sees
cultural warfare as a means to create
enduring change and the American palate
the one thing spent computer you you
notice that this was the headline but
you and I both went in for a quote the
guy doesn't say that Savannah use it to
suppress the black vote there's no where
anything about black vote no there's no
where nothing I must have misread that
no no I didn't miss me at all
they got it wrong because the dad
actually showed that would have been
just as effective
okay Steve Aidan hiding in blind
people's closets that would have worked
better at this scare me also by the way
really quickly this is the whistleblower
for those who don't know in question I
am concerned that we made Russia aware
of the programs that we were working on
and that might have sparked an idea that
you know eventually led to some of the
disinformation programs that we've seen
in the interference that we've seen from
from Russia in American elections holy
crap it's a male lesbian feminist how
even possible a Canadian hipster one no
less I feel like a cosmic wormhole was
creating a parallel socialist
basement-dwelling universe and I I think
you heard
want want want want want suppress black
vote yeah and there's some where you can
watch the whole thing I encourage you to
ya know I go back to bed think I had a
friend who chats has his wife for heaven
or irrational fear of sharks and I said
that's not irrational at all it's a very
rational fear no she thinks they're
under her bed oh yeah good chance I
think that is irrational it's hi there
show there's a good chance to Bannon is
in your bed yes suppressing your vote
right and yet sometimes he puts on a
shark outside the realms of possibility
he puts on a shark head because he likes
to laugh but seriously the
whistleblowers Bible can be a real pain
we've actually we've had problems here
with the in yeah spend computer not good
joke we're okay that's not exactly okay
I appreciate it yeah thanks thanks for
reading on your fellow lighters good wow
Soros have you learned nothing hey hot
lines for that alright dot Elon Musk by
the way he's back in the news that's
always a good topic to cover we don't
get anger with that because Thursday
Tesla data confirmed that the wrecked
Model S was in fact an autopilot when I
hit a truck at 60 miles per hour first
quick to brag on it was Elon Musk
himself tweeting what's actually amazing
about this accident is that the
month-old s hit the fire truck at 60
miles per hour and the driver only
broken ankle at an impact that's but
usually it results in severe injury or
death timing Elon timings he went on to
tweet and especially when taking into
account that it was a female
oriental AI robot the hands via for
which we have uncharacteristically low
expectations come on for our little
robots eat no touch the petal I robot me
log fee while you find my feet a robot
my shoes are slipping in almost almost
seems senseless I mean kind of shooting
out of a learning computer well [ __ ] I
do Shawn did that hide the car I go six
per hour just because is my favorite
story of the week a man at a local news
story almost God is purse stolen and he
made really clear that he was not going
to be giving up his Louie Vuitton bag
hopefully we get him as a guest role
give me your bag and I was like you're
not kidding my Louis Vuitton I worked
very hard for this I got my bags you
could pry it out of my cold dead hands
the confidence is actually well-earned
when you realize he's a black belt in
judo so yeah he looks like the guy who
killed Versace for people who don't
watch it you solo the batting back if
the next words alles mouth were I love I
identify as I hate I talk about such
deep meaning no it just means expensive
it's expensive so you get to be caddy
with other gay guys but I would like to
have him on the show absolutely if
you've got a person that's loaded it's a
weapon so Russia by the way because it's
in the news we have to because you know
it's a show news Thursday for billion
dollar Crimea bridge but they finished
it they fidget but Vladimir Putin Putin
I said this is gonna be I mean I'm gonna
get so much hate mail for this Putin
he's a great man he's country you
believe in the western brother he's real
chill he wanted to be the first across
the bridge but he was beaten by a cat
cat got to it first so that cat by the
way was never seen again
Tilly was fingered action as a
ringleader in Capra channel it occurs
Russian data collecting cats scandals so
that's yeah yeah it's almost almost like
he's he thinks that he's above the law
12 hours is not nothing there's no doubt
he used yes yes hundred percent chance
at the very least he was on EPO there
they actually called Jared to come take
care of the problem he knows how to kill
pets this is true that cage area has a
long race killing gluten
hey speaking of killing things 25 year
old Texas man is in serious trouble
after he was posing as a 17 year old
high school student in order Olivia's
glory days in the basketball squad it's
like high school musical meets rape so
the real story from Dallas news Sidney
Bouvier Gilstrap portly that's also
that's a bunch of names Henry Schmitt
his name was my date underage girls
began the school year at Skyline High
School let make sure I get this right
because a lot of moving pieces there he
enrolled claiming to be a hurricane
Harvie refugee so necessary a little
eight months later transferred to
Hillcrest High School where a dated a 14
year old classmate and joined the
basketball team of course he would
yeah it makes you feel good that that's
in your own backyard in the United
States lest you look down your nose at
other nations of course I was is highly
illegal and once it was discovered to
school was preparing to expel him pursue
legal action so we just slept on a pair
of tights and and went on to win the
female state wrestling titles so all is
well that ends well the dude could still
be dunking on [ __ ] today see that in
the first place you just gotta do a
little think about this no trans ageism
is far more rational the transgenderism
I mean at one point uy is 17 it's true
and you can have a young kid with a high
IQ or an adult who has a fourth-grade
learning level so it's far more
reasonable at one point he's experienced
it he did he never he's never had a
vagina I don't really like the path were
going down it almost seems as though
we're excusing this how stupid do you
have to be to see a 25 year old man and
think he's 17 I mean it's like I'm not
Jake Garrard kind of they're probably
watching too much of the CW network
washing it were 35 year olds play 18
year olds and recruit for sex cults they
were looking at state championship use
for basketball sweet arrow reruns this
is this is Australia everyone I was
vetoed in the pitch meeting we haven't
suffered a Canadian woman has now been
detained and that seems remarkably mild
when he has a rest of the story has been
only detained after getting angry the
Tim Hortons defecating on the floor and
proceeding to hurl it at the employees
so usually we would withhold judgment
from these kinds of stories say you
alright wait till all the evidence comes
in works like a ledger words like
allegedly but in this case we have we're
very damning footage and look yeah make
sure we got we have please we have to
borrow this for the I know you know what
[Laughter]
what I find so crazy about that is sheet
for those who are listening the audio
version she picks up what she picks up
the feces she throws it and then she
grabs a paper towel and because there's
no you
is that like a sling and then she throws
a paper towel so this is the not the
first time he's done this and by the way
for those who haven't seen the clip and
I know we had to blur
that's some serious philosophy on that
drafted said the rebooted Montreal Expos
curveballs and sliders have a whole new
meaning yes I don't know I don't know
how that applies to curveballs that must
be you because there's no call them that
one alone yeah I'm mad you have to be to
take a crap on the floor though it's not
so much yeah that's a good pour hot it's
not high do you have - it's about intent
pooping spitefully is very disturbing it
takes a minute she popped that out
pretty fast I mean like it's like she
can do it on command like like it's just
it's like it's anger poop yeah morons
isn't even that great by the way but the
doughnuts are the oh come on now you're
given your Givens you're given us all
work that's okay we're better than all
right so uh about you I think actually
here to discuss we do have to discuss
what happened to Jane Goodall yeah movie
by the way Congo sucked which was
loosely based on Jane Goodall that's not
true none of it is true I just wanted to
make sure we have enough time to bring
on our next guest actually to discuss
this issue it's a prime minister of
Canada where I was raised I I think do
we have him here Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau are you here sir yes thanks for
having me Stephen I I think what's most
important for people stateside to
understand is that this is not in any
way representative of all the citizens
of Canada I don't I don't think any of
us thought that it was representative
although citizens of Canada no I don't
think that see well at the same time I
want to extend a hand of grace and
understanding to our oft maligned and
misunderstood throwing community and I
said I think that a vibrant and rich
addition to Canada's people kind I don't
think that's an actual subset that's not
a community at all
I found that contrary to your approach
in the United States here in Canada
conflict is not our our first course of
action but and I don't know the
upbringing of this young Canadian lady
in the Tim Hortons and until I've walked
a mile in her steamy shoes no see that's
a big could not be less relevant her
from this is why what yeah
I failed again see all right listen
Prime Minister Trudeau this is a crime
I'm sorry story here okay what's the
mouth get rid of all right prime
minister justin trudeau everybody that's
enough we shouldn't have him on the show
anymore Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
he's also very difficult to frame
properly predictable in this responses
bizarre arms too as well for wine that
footage for those who missed it find an
easter egg
we apologize there we go okay so no
strong opinions on that and the flinging
feces no all right okay so let's get to
this we got a lot of feedback on this
we've talked about this for those who
are not among club members in The Daily
Show quite a bit this idea of the Nordic
socialist model yeah right we hear this
quite a bit and this was used well they
keep moving the goalposts and that's
what's important here we hear
socialism's work so now we hear well
place like venezuela didn't do socialism
correctly right even though they were
being praised not long ago by Sean Penn
and Paulo everybody in the London Bernie
Sanders so they keep moving and they see
boho second the Nordic countries are we
should model those and if don't take my
word for it socialism I'm not looking at
Venezuela I'm not looking at Cuba I'm
looking at countries like Denmark and
Sweden is it really possible for someone
who calls himself a socialist to be
elected president United States well so
long as we know what democratic
socialism is and if we know that in
countries in Scandinavia like Denmark
Norway Sweden in those countries health
care is a right of all people in those
countries college education graduate
school is free in those countries
retirement benefits child care are
stronger than in the United States of
America okay a couple of things we're
gonna get to actually the danish prime
minister who said that's not true I
think it's important okay Marley was
dead to begin with it's people need to
understand these scheme and even
countries they don't they don't owe
their success to socialism they actually
became very wealthy first off under free
market economies and then later imposed
by the way in some forms so in some ways
they're certainly further to the left of
the United States but in other ways
we'll get to like corporate tax rates
not even close but later on after they
built their economy imposed some high
taxes and large welfare states so for
instance 1870 through 1936 Sweden was
the fastest growing economy in the world
but after 1975 when as we assured expand
the welfare
state its economic growth starting to
trawl after that Scandinavian countries
begin reducing the size reducing the
size of the government if you look at
you look at okay gross
alright implemented welfare state yeah
and then standstill and they start
reducing it so since the nineteen ninety
is a total taxation of the Swedish
economy is a percentage of the GDP has
fallen more than five percent yeah so I
wanted to interrupt real quick on these
points like we're a lot of people will
believe this a lot of people will
believe what Bernie Sanders just said
right and so it's all of our
responsibility it's not Steven hey great
job you go get them everybody tune in
pick out these points and be able to
tell your friends because they're going
to believe that this is true because the
media won't call him on it is very
common that anywhere else so you have to
do it we all have to do it with us too
we'll have these sources up you can see
the overlays here on the screen I want
you to call us on this okay
yeah I I don't don't just nod your head
with what were saying this is the
opposite of Trevor Noah saying as
audience we want you to watch what they
say entirely and then watch what we say
and if we're wrong call us so much I'm
sure I'll get something wrong today so
one thing to these these places it's the
pure it's the purity they try to argue
like well it's not real socialism
Venezuela you think that a place like
Sweden is more socialist than Venezuela
the prime minister of Denmark just
recently said again the Nordic model
still isn't socialist okay Bernie
socialism involves abolishing the free
market return that means production to
people's government like in Venezuela
that's what social so this is one thing
that people often do this is the bait
and switch right they go they go well
it's worked in Nordic countries where
they have socialized how c'mon think
that's not that's not socialism if
there's one thing right and certainly
not if you're saying well it didn't work
in Venezuela it didn't work in places
like Cuba because they didn't it wasn't
real socialism
that's the again the importance here is
a consistency of standards okay they're
mostly free market economies in these
Nordic countries right and literally
riding the coattails of of capitalism
yes exactly
either because they have to either
collapse or get back on the coattails of
capital so something is very surprising
to a lot of people is is even though
they have very high income taxes for
individuals ok corporate tax rates for
businesses are mostly is it'll
significantly lower than the United
States
so Denmark Denmark you son-of-a-bitch
sorry people which one do you do
Denmark's corporate tax or anyone know
what it is it's pretty high I mean
pretty low relative sorry he's like
24% screwed over Norway 27% which is
high Sweden is 22 the u.s. is under
Obama was 39 percent was the highest
feeling the corporate tax rate and now
evil right-wing Trump wants to lower it
to 26% which is still higher than sweet
nobody has bad hair that's true I just
love this by the way in case and Kate
but you don't have to take my word for
it in case you think I'm making this up
as far as the Danes and being a little
bit tired of Bernie regurgitating this
an American media unchecked tail the
tape the major fluke apart from the
sender left and the sender right would
oppose many of the proposals of Bernie
Sanders on the regulatory side as being
[Laughter]
and I'm gonna take what dead Johnny
Mathis Don Lemon has to say again this
is the this is the last corner where
they point to we hear this all time ago
what about this country we talk about
this offend kabir north well obviously
north korea's is further along the trail
and socialist but there if you look back
in the nineteen in the 1950s north korea
area they had grown power with south
korea for a while and then crash yeah
exactly because you can fake this for a
while you can just take the money and
pay for it in a short time like we saw
by the way we also saw with venezuela
while you guys were praising it we're
still gonna call you you don't get
together there's no get out of venezuela
free card there yeah joe we've done the
exact same thing with some of the
socialistic kind of programs that we've
implemented united states after
successful periods of economic growth
and we tend to do that every single time
we succeed then we try to give everybody
right new stuff realize it doesn't work
and go back to working hard right they
hope that happens the consistency of
standards and coheres is really it's an
important point that they the only
places they have left to point to are
these Nordic models who survived their
socials and by diluting it with
capitalism and the corporate tax rates
and something else that's really
interesting I'll get to in a second but
again this is another myth that they
claim the Nordic model would work here
in the United States the comparison is
asinine but they hear them say first and
I think we should look to countries like
Denmark like Sweden and Norway and learn
from what they have accomplished
for their working people he wants
America to look more like Scandinavia
that's right that's right
and what's wrong with that okay I think
there's a lot wrong with this a couple
of things here several things wrong part
of what okay
they're almost inadvertent ethno states
yeah they were for a long time just get
a name it part of the reason the model
works in these countries is that they
are incredibly small yeah right very
very small entirely homogenous
populations with a very industrious
culture okay do you think that it is
more likely or less likely to take
something that barely worked in these
countries again I people can't even
afford used cars in Denmark because of
some of these taxes and they're scaling
it back he's more likely less likely to
work in the United States just look at
how we've invented socialism here and
also really does matter to look at how
look at Social Security you look at the
Obama care
look it's look at public education these
are not shining beacons of success in
the United States these are staying
generally speaking on our history
there's take really inefficient programs
and supersize them yeah you can't think
a country that has the population of
Delaware that isn't Mahler and by the
way has has a national identity which
was which was based on being an entirely
homogeneous culture for a long time not
not a not a series of ideas for a long
time I don't even know what Bernie at
this point runs the long cuz he's still
throwing this out there but at some
point with with the success of trumps
tax cuts
what is he out there pitching he's only
you can only point to more free stuff
that these models have right exactly I
stole that what go in farther he won't
work and the tap by the way the tax cut
or freeze quote from President Donald R
on our our popular
yes about their plurality with because
most people actually seeing you know cut
they're seeing more money coming home in
their paycheck so drugs is more popular
now I don't know I don't know what you
do I don't know what bring us you know
the wealthiest 1% but I but I'm getting
I'm getting more on my paycheck bail the
myth is gone the once it's been
implemented you've been kind of like
with democratic socialism you've been
fed a mess no it turns you've heard him
sell you the Nordic model of socialism
until you realize within it then the
Danes say no no that's actually not true
he's completely factually incorrect
you've heard
describe what the tax cuts were going to
be I was only going to benefit the Koch
brothers and then you see it in practice
that's what's important it's not just
the words but the actions and again big
first of a couple of is I find fight
isn't going to change because the
migrant crisis yeah and they've found
different ways to solve the problem
Denmark just making itself as
unattractive to migrants as possible
Finland Finland already had that covers
remember they walked into Finland said
no they left he had the corner on ugly
refugee yes
there was nothing in Finland that they
wanted but a big big reason that these
countries are successful is they're
industrious culture no people gonna say
oh that's that that's a racist argument
no no no listen I'm talking about their
history these people the kind of culture
they've been steeped in for a long time
so here's some this is something I
thought was incredibly interesting read
our researcher brought this to my
attention I did not know this until
about six months ago okay if you take
these from Sweden from Denmark from
these countries and you transplant them
to the United States of America so you
transplant them from these supposedly
socialist utopias their standards of
living actually go up not down Danish
Americans take the person take the
culture transplant their living
standards are fifty five percent higher
than those in Denmark living centers of
Swedish Americans are 53 percent higher
than those in Sweden Finnish Americans
living in said it's a fifty-nine percent
higher than those in Finland there's
nice berries taste like snozzberries
it's almost like there's a stronger
coalition between industriousness yeah
it is
so incontrovertible at that point so
these are again these are go back to we
said Delaware but large let's say Ohio
let's be generous right not gay Jared
you're a big fan of Ohio for whatever
reason he'll know what's been going on
with it with the NBA that's a good way
to set up for nigel for us let's get
jeered as upset as humanly possible do
we think it's fair to make this
comparison this is a genuine question do
you think it's fair to compare let's say
Denmark or Iceland or Sweden to the
United States a country of 300 plus
million people which is unbelievably
diverse in comparison No okay let's
let's take another step let's say you
think it's fair you think it's a fair
comparison you still think it'll work
well then would we say that it's equally
fair or maybe a more fair comparison
let's say like California soup
super liberal state the United States
versus say Texas so blue policy left
policy versus right policy here in the
United States bigger populations and a
lot of the countries are talking about
and both in the same country will be
saying this may be this may be one apt
comparison okay because Texas is
actually right as a best state for
business twelve years and right boom
there's a reason Jeff Bezos isn't
scouting Los Angeles right to the next
it was worst by the way California for
12 years in running some of the highest
powered originally the United States and
of course the opposite of Texas the
California some the highest taxes Texas
has no state income tax by the way and a
surplus that's right I mean there's no
City no there's nice to get together
with a tax but there's a surplus yeah
yeah we have more money we have more
money that we're spending more money so
much winning would do me a favor all you
Californians on this just just remember
this when you move to the state of Texas
right yes your policies behind well the
reason we use those two stars out is
because they're both very large states
they're both very diverse states
they're both it wouldn't be fair to
let's say Vicki Connor California versus
Rhode Island right or wouldn't be fair
to compare Texas and I don't know
Wyoming these are two very large states
both in top five states in population
and in landmass two states with a lot of
natural resources right so let's they
often use that with Venezuela well it's
the oil issue really try to imagine
socialism without sitting on a giant bed
of what it doesn't get any better I can
tell you how this ends if you choose
your own path and bread lines yeah
so it's a more for Texas in California
where the purest sort of its appears
compare so we can have in the United
States unbelievably different
unbelievably different outcomes and a
direct correlation with Californians
leaving California specifically to Texas
for work if it worked here first up
Detroit would be a utopia we've talked
about that not exactly I highly
recommend that you visit sure some
hipsters have set up some some coffee
shops and nailed some Dockers to a tree
and then want to call it art right next
to the meth fire but comparing
California to Texas I believe is a fair
comparison certainly more than comparing
these countries to the United States and
even then these countries are not the
pure example of social it's not a lot of
these goalposts to move call me on it
call them on it don't just nod your head
here in agreement I want you to do the
research I want you to find out what
socialism is read the definition of
social read whatever books you want on
social right don't even don't even have
to take my word for a bar
burn you're better off taking the word
of a six-year-old I like the black with
the pop-ups mmm nuts that's absolutely a
fascinating captain so I recommend you
do research and socialism okay
then compare the list of Venezuela
compare the list of places like a lot of
countries in South America of Cuba with
textbook definition first is the Nordic
model what's most like socialism and
then just throw them all out because
none of it really works that well we
have Nigel Faraj coming up after the
break with the yeah we have to have him
let's go monetization does not exist on
this platform does it notifications do
not exist on this platform does it no
free speech does not exist on this
platform does it those that day what do
we say here whether YouTube started what
is that way a face is no dissent
notifications are I can't hear you baby
faces notice that no notifications are
mr. dog a larks warm them up I burn
print out positions CZ r c zu z r 0 Z Z
Z Z
I love him he's the mack daddy of the UK
around here we say it pays to keep your
Nigel hands strong you know him as mr.
brexit follow him on the Twitter at
Nigel underscore Faraj mr. Faraj thank
you for being back sir
great I am so excited to have you a big
week internationally so we you know we
have international guests here on this
show a couple of things I wanted to get
into I know it's topical and we don't
have a ton of time but one thing that is
incredibly interesting is you've
proposed that Donald Trump be nominated
for the Nobel Peace Prize but your your
reasoning I thought was very interesting
here to explain for people who aren't
well Obama got the Nobel Peace Prize
because the committee thought he was so
nice and so lovely that he do great
things as president so he got a Nobel
Peace Prize for what they thought he
might do this president is actually
doing stuff and okay I know in the last
48 hours you know Rocketman Kim you know
I might not go if you demand Audi
already what yeah absolutely but what
the president's achieved by firstly by
talking tough by not appeasing bad
people what he's also achieved by
persuading China that they absolutely
have to put proper sanctions on North
Korea right already you know we've had a
summit between North Korea and South
Korea there's gonna be a meeting the
Singapore meeting will happen so I think
the president is making stuff happen and
if anyone deserves a Nobel Peace Prize
it's him and so after the summit I'm
gonna go to the European Parliament and
start a petition to ask European
politicians to sign it I mean it could
be quite a small signature this yes yes
and it puts them in a corner because
talk about losing faith in your
institutions if Oh
to be fair president brocco bomb I did
have a beer summit with that that police
officer and that black guy I remember
that because they preferred blue moon
that was a big deal here in the United
States so baby steps yes you this mister
Faraj uh so people here keep talking
first off how do you get along with the
prime minister trudeau I be spend any
time with him no he's a new Trinity for
me we can use you know people have been
just complaining about the bricks and
obviously people on the Left and there's
been this back and forth and I like that
you've said all right you put your money
where your mouth is you've talked about
potentially now it's a word I'm familiar
with from Quebec referendum a second
referendum on brexit explain that
because stateside some people don't
necessarily know okay let me be clear I
do not want a second referendum on
brexit we've had the referendum we won
we beat the establishment it was never
supposed to be the best of three but
what we have here what we have here is
we have much of our political
establishment who are doing everything
they can to water down brexit to delay
brexit and if they can I'm talking about
the Tony Blair's of this world right and
people like that and if they can they
will do what they have well anything
within their power to force us to vote
again and all I'm saying to people is if
you voted brexit and you're pleased with
the result
don't be complacent because these guys
may ask us to do it again and if they
have and if we do face it back it's the
worst case scenario but if we do face
that next time we're gonna crush him yes
I want to clarify what I was saying best
three out of five is my belief when it
comes to this best best three out of
five it's like when you're playing wall
ball as a kid so we had a five we'll go
three we'll go three sets well go three
seven a huge week for president listen
I'm man enough to admit when I we talked
about this this week when we were
incorrect I thought the risk with
President Trump is that obviously he's
bombastic to a lot of people he's he's a
polarizing figure for good and for bad
and I thought oh that could hurt
Republicans in the long run it seems to
me after these last couple weeks first
off the tax cut is wildly popular which
is very very hard to do with any kind of
an economic proposal let alone actually
a piece of legislation then you have
Iran North Korea and now of course the
embassy in
Jerusalem I wanted to get your take on
this I actually listen to your radio
show and you talked about how this was a
good thing actually I think you said it
was imperative for the United States
Embassy to be in Jerusalem but I was
very confused because during the
election during the brexit the media
said that you of course racist
anti-semitic and all of the above nobody
had ever called me anti-semitic until I
attack George Soros he's our Mary
intervention in you know our world right
across the West but you attack Soros
they call you any Semitic right I think
what's really important here Trump stood
before the American public and said I
will do this this and this I will break
the Iran nuclear deal it's not working I
will not just say as the bushes did and
Clinton did and abominate that I'll move
the embassy to Jerusalem I will actually
do it and the really important thing
about Trump is that what he is doing is
he is genuinely restoring voters faith
in a democratic process he's delivering
what he said he do and all the others on
both sides of the pond make promises to
get votes without even having the
intention right of putting those things
into practice so I admire him hugely for
it and as far as Jerusalem is concerned
well that lines now moved any future
negotiations have to work on the basis
that Jerusalem is the capital of Israel
exactly that's how it is and if people
don't like it sorry listen we had
elections a guy delivered on his promise
this is by the way he delivered like you
said on Obama's promise so just consider
it Linton's promise yes we considered a
belated promise delivery from President
Obama let's give him that one I just
like their saying that well the tax the
tax break they're gonna hurt you ten
years down the line as it gets more
popular you might see some savings in
your paycheck now but ten years down the
line let's just chalk this up for
President Obama ten years down the line
Jerusalem embassy final question mister
frosh let me ask you this we've talked
about this quite a bit now being raised
in Canada I have a lot
family in Canada and you have two
different points of view right that
Donald Trump has hurt our standing
abroad as far as how were seen as
Americans respected and then have
another point of view mine where we talk
about Iran kim jeong-hoon
and actually seeing power up through
strength here what is your opinion on
that internationally how do you think
people leave the United States who was a
say was given the Nobel Peace Prize was
treated by the British media as the
second coming of Jesus Christ is
wonderful man who derived and who put
down red lines in Syria which once they
were crossed he didn't respond to an
America America's status across the
world shrank within the course of those
eight years what a stone people about
Trump's presidency more than any other
single thing is right from the moment he
got off that aeroplane in Riyadh Saudi
Arabia his first overseas visit is the
way that he's carried and conducted
himself on the world stage do you know
when he was in Beijing walking around
the capital of China right he looked so
at ease and so confident I thought he
was about to put a bid in to buy the
place I would be surprised if he did
well what he's finished as president
that could be Trump Beijing you never
know honestly he's achieved amazing
things on the world stage and when he
speaks people listen and I think they
also know Trump does not appease people
yes if Trump said if Trump says you're a
bully and I'm gonna stand up to you
those bullies swallow hard and say hmm
this is one president who perhaps means
it it was a result of all that America's
standing in the world is far greater
than it was when you took office well
damn
I will I will absolutely do us that
sometimes he almost doubles down were
someone I'm really not a Bellini and
sometimes it's justifiable all he's not
a boolean traffic no he's a bully I
already decided to be fair the second
coming of Christ with President Barack
Obama
I hate to fact-check here but it was
misleading with the verses and
revelations talking about him
raising Indonesia doing cocaine with his
college professor it's very very easy to
get that confused with the end times and
make a false prediction mr. Nigel Faraj
Nigel underscore Faraj on Twitter thank
you so much sir I know you're busy
appreciate you taking the time sir thank
you and we're back after this with Owen
Benjamin Lawrence others
[Music]
it's library time usually the mutt Club
library but this week we actually gonna
talk about something we've incredibly
appreciative but we do need you to sign
up at ladders credit.com slash Marco to
support the daily show but this week we
want to talk about someone who's
supported our show an unbelievable and
that's Walter firearms they've been a
sponsor for the show for a while it
started out with us just being fans of
the firearms it's such an easy sponsor
to have because we always tell people I
listen there plenty of great firearms
out there okay we're not saying well but
we just recommend you try the wall 302 a
gunnery I just tried out I'm like I
wasn't even my radar yeah it's just made
it so easy to so awesome and of course
we've done several videos at the gun
range we've taken two before their first
time every single time they either went
on to buy a Walther or wanted to buy a
Walther but they couldn't because they
were too young I've seen in the last
change my mind because she was not 21
years old let alone fact you can't buy a
man unless you're 21 so this is their
ppq their full size model easiest
firearm to shoot just google Walther PPQ
reviews and then this right here is of
course what a lot of us carry that's the
PPS which I'm a huge fan as well
Walter firearms just try it go to a gun
range go to a firearm range try it and
see if you like it because they do
they've had the balls to stand up and
actually support this program and there
are a lot of people will do that we've
actually had people ask us to not
mention their products I just talked
about products on air incidentally they
said can you not can you not do that we
don't want to be associated with this
show because you know we want to go on
we want to make sure David hog is a
shout out on his Instagram so Walter
firearms thank you guys so much and if
you want to support a sponsor that
supports the show and it's a great
product anyway Walter firearms louder
with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter I got so much more
than that with people doing it at my
club a lot of a corner comes a smoke up
because I combined them on blueberries
and [ __ ] everybody lines up but I won't
send them all back
[Music]
take off a moto
[Music]
[Music]
see get the ball look at the bomb get
the ball because that would be
distasteful this week that would be a
little too tasteful therefore that it's
distasteful any week second la still has
control of the Gaza Strip really good to
have our next guest we're gonna have a
little ditty on from him later on the
show the last commercial break but right
now we're having him as a human as a
human being as well you can follow his
story between the Pacific Northwest here
soon at huge pianist calm and his
YouTube channel I think is Owen Benjamin
comedy Owen do I do I have that right
you do my friend and I am a real a real
human being yes I know Owen knows that
people watching two minutes Crowder you
really should update our little yeah
yeah you rested up there Laura thorough
realize your lower third still has your
Twitter on there I'm sorry see our TV
show and and it listed everyone's
Twitter and it just said mine banned
banned and then someone searched at band
I know that's just that's a pornography
advertisement Steve hey it's being the
bizarre app it's you were telling me
this during the break a Pittsburgh
newspaper editor said you were an all
right not something along those lines
got fired right which is incredibly rare
for you to put one over on them so hats
off to you it's uh it was really
exciting and I only know it because my
wife is actually even more spiteful than
I am so so she will keep up on the
people that have lied and slandered me
and she just comes in today and she's
like that guy who lied and said you were
this racist outright guy the editor got
fired and she was like how great is that
I'm like baby I love that you love me
and we're not enemy that happens so you
gotta savor it when it does it was he
fired because of what he said about you
or is it incident who's also doing it to
like every Republican like just anybody
on the right yeah so I think that it
just uh it just started adding up to the
point where he got axed which was uh
which is great news but now you're not
as special I'm not you know I I'm not as
special but I do start I am starting to
think that uh the news may be lying to
us yes I think they might be misleading
kind of like we spoke about earlier I
know your song later is about Palestine
you know fifty some people dead
in the conflict Tarrant listened loss of
life tragedy but then you look it was
twenty something I think we're convicted
terrorists or suspected terrorists
that's that's what we called them in a
certain point and then why we're babies
there to begin with
everything about bring you ladies yeah
everything about bringing your baby two
to inner city Detroit their own leaving
it on a liquor store corner no I feel
weird when he's in like the rain yeah
yeah to repair his only rating mustard
gas so it's a little different because
in in law you have to factor in intent
and this is what I found so interesting
about because you never know about the
middle east it's been a mess for a long
time but I was watching it and you see
like Western media like New York Times
and they're like all of these people
want is to be neighbors and peaceful and
and and then you see like these these
crazy Palestine's be like no we want to
kill the Jew disease no that's not what
they really want and they're like no all
of them and Christians like that's what
we want to do and I'm like they're
telling us what their plan is right how
many disease I don't think you know what
you know I feel pretty good about it the
one that you want me to polo Rome hold
on one one minute crush it should be
super sleep on it no no this is never
sleep on that's kind of a separator we
did never change reading about it like
Hamas it's like a Twitter handle it's
like if you retreat a hundred times we
will blow up do for you it is oh by the
way at scary guy not necessarily the
dialogue in here from an altar rightist
I don't know all brightest altar writer
I don't even know with Owen Benjamin ya
know what that is I don't even means
yeah I'm not I'm not entirely sure
anymore either they've tried to use it
to mean like it's basically they want
everyone to think that all all trite
people are Eddie furlong for American
History X you know pre Redemption um but
I don't I I don't know I don't know what
it means anymore either it seems like
it's been so this is what the left has
done right they've diluted it so much
doesn't mean anything anymore just like
if they've screamed that the Trump's guy
is falling for so long that no one
believes it anymore and he's become it
makes them bulletproof it makes people
like you bulletproof no one's gonna
believe them anymore when they say that
Owen did something shocking and alarming
which you probably will do at some point
but it will involve more more probable
like a slingshot in my neighbors windows
or something like this yes exactly and
it's
like I think it was Paul a Steve McQueen
and Frank Zappa he shot his windows out
with a shotgun because he wouldn't turn
the bathroom light off in Malibu that's
amazing
I could see it like like like race is
probably one of the last things I would
ever rate a person on like for me it's a
lot more about height
yes I'm let's just say I like your
height buddy that's one reason why I
think we became such good friends so
quickly respect each other's high I
appreciate it one would to say that you
almost have an unfair advantage being
6/8 though that it's it's like you went
too far I went past the money zone I
can't ride on rollercoasters and I'll
die before you this is true yeah this is
absolutely true your heart has to pump
it to all your limbs and hey I found
this out today baby aspirin my doctor
spoke with my for you you should know
this own as a big guy cuz you know
you'll die young my dad tested and they
said they were doing all these tests for
sort of you don't hear your your sort of
I guess your rate your risk ratio the
risk assessment for coronary heart
disease and II said will no good
cholesterol good blood pressure all this
exercise diets he said but my dad did
have a stroke and they said do you take
a baby aspirin he said every day since
my father had a stroke I think in 1997
93 I can't remember exactly and they
said that entirely eliminates the
genetic component to stroke and almost
completely eliminates early stroke
period it provided everything else as is
normal you're healthy so take a baby
aspirin
you know maybe you'll make it to 64 yeah
but most my family lives real real long
but back then they were like 511 but
they were like LED miners like they were
still the tallest dudes yes I think I
got I got enough nutrition now to really
enter a bad zone so I'm gonna have to
get in a baby aspirin cuz like if I get
hit in the foot I don't feel it for like
a half hour yes well well you know it
enjoy it while you can
of course I mean I suspect my doctor's
been paid by by big aspirin the aspirin
he's collecting those dollar 50 CVS the
American brand specs if people are just
freebasing baby aspirin yes exactly
okay oh and where are you going to be
next you're you're touring so big pns
calm and ice at the Pacific Northwest
pianist is a huge pianist I'm sorry it's
all good
some sometimes people mess up how I
describe being a pianist yes I hope you
know Portland Richland Washington and
Bellevue Washington and yeah you can
take it to my website and also at my you
janna I do live streams every day yeah I
mean ya know Owen Benjamin comedy and
what dates what dates are they starting
the Pacific Northwest to our fields I
don't know June 2nd 4th 5th right in
that zone and it's gonna be a blast most
of them are already sold out and and now
I'm starting to not get protested like I
did because I think people jumped on me
because of the you know the trans kid
thing and then a few other things and
then once you like research me realize
I'm not really that protest able and
then they kind of like die out like like
teething children that's what's happened
what's happened with us after the year
actually after the Virginia Tech show
kind of with SMU people realize there's
everyone's having such a good time just
really has a gift when you're not living
for that right exactly we're not wait
you know the dental we just want to do a
show like you you know there's some
people who show up and they just want to
protest we want to do the show I think
people when they show up and they see
everyone laugh and everyone having a
good time that's why comedy is so
important they go like oh maybe maybe
I'm the ball you know if they're
protesting so it's disarmed it yeah it's
like that old joke where two Nazis are
standing next to each other and one's
like hey Franz we have skulls on our
lapels do you think we might be the bad
guys yeah I remember that was it where's
that I know you told it I don't know
that's no one but it that's exactly it
you I think they have this realization
when they're there and you gave me flack
for not getting huge pianist correct and
he doesn't know what city he's going to
be in anyways you guys can check it out
huge pianist calm Owen we have to go
you'll be back with your song during the
commercial break thank you very much sir
I believe do we have we should we're
connecting now we have Lauren she's
there no okay at Lauren underscore
southern Lauren thank your being with us
absolutely I'm glad to have you so I now
you're back in from Owens face yes nice
change of refreshing change of pace from
up from Owens point now you're back in
Canada because you're not allowed in the
UK right I have that correct yes that is
that is correct because I'm gonna see
how many countries I can get banned from
before I'm like 30 or something yes oh
how many was it Italy in the UK now I'm
not banned from Italy yet working on
that though I have trouble getting in
okay I'm gonna try to immerse Brittany
Pettibone at it you'll see okay so
alright so so now is it
all of the UK yeah it's all of the UK so
I can't even anyway so there there's a
kind of an alliance against you really
what the you were so much cooler than me
I'm just banned from a few selected
movie theatres and this is true yeah and
then Ohio
yes I'm Ben from patreon - I guess
that's not quite a country yet no once
we start having corporations buying
their own islands and creating their own
nations then maybe I'll be banned from
somewhere yes
well patreon little-known fact has 1800
times the GDP of Ghana also the first
country Barack Obama visited so there's
that you could you could can put that as
an arrow in your quiver
you'll probably band pretty soon you
because you've been doing this film
called farmland right I wouldn't go back
to South Africa so even though I'm not
officially banned right I've been
getting calls from people saying do not
go back to South Africa whatever you do
but yes my film foreign lines it's been
a nightmare getting it done in the
background people are like where is it
Lorne where is it but it will be out
this month 100% on the crisis going on
in South Africa with the farm murders
the crazy anti white policies coming
from the ANC and just the overall chaos
drought and nightmare that South Africa
is right now yes okay well so you're not
going back to South Africa anytime soon
but I don't know that they don't
necessarily have you will call that one
a wash for people who don't know this
this what what is going on here
in South Africa peep citizens are taking
tactical training themselves and now
you've talked about this nuts in your
film farm lands and I appreciate that by
the way it's gonna because she's not
pointing any to sarkeesian the film
should actually be completed it's
raining it you know see strong woman
over hurdles overcomes them she jumps
over them like Bruce Jenner before he
was Caitlyn we know has fallen through
yes used to be known as follow through
now they're there they're arming
themselves they're willing to protect
themselves against this is some of the
people miss government-backed Marauders
as a Canadian in a country where it's
very difficult to obtain firearms are
certainly the Second Amendment is very
foreign to them how did how did you
relate to this thing us in South Africa
and it did it ring some bells for kind
of thinking stateside the Second
Amendment how important it is yes so
it's actually extremely difficult to get
firearms in South Africa as well when we
played the trailer for farmlands we had
some footage in someone's window and
showing firearms on the wall and I was
worried because tons of people were like
Lauren you're trying to exaggerate those
are just paintball guns on their wall
those aren't real guns which is true
most of the people buy paintball guns so
they can stock up with pepper balls and
everything for self-defense because they
can't get real guns we met up with a
woman no that you wouldn't know that
seeing the videos with South Africa just
Justin Jett that'll only pissed them off
if that's a that's why she ever no get
out a government-backed Marauder on
crack I don't think a pepper paintball
is gonna do it but sorry continue yeah
yeah so people try to defend themselves
in all kinds of ways with electric
fences paintball guns the rest of it and
for the few people that can get guns
which they are desperately trying to get
them now yes they are practicing
self-defense because the government has
basically given a free for all for the
ban to blacks to take white land which
important thing here for people to
understand the ban to blacks which are
the tribes that run most of the ANC
government are not indigenous to the
land the Khoisan natives are and the
Khoisan natives are not getting any of
the land from white people that is now
being redistributed by the government so
there's an all-out attack on white
people right now for their land the
government has said go ahead take it in
fact we're gonna go in and forcefully
take it and the Boer people are training
with whatever they can get if they can
get guns they're using that if they can
get paint balls most of it is just for
self-defense purposes go back there and
tell them not to use the paintballs I
would tell them you'd be better off just
sharpening pointy sticks than paint
balls they'd be better off trying to
find an ACME anvil that they can hit a
button and drop on somebody it's a more
realistic expectation than fighting
these people off with paintball
therefore a really good point there's
this one girl who I met with and this
will be in the documentary she runs one
of those paintball studios who sells
stuff to the poor people and people are
just actually want to go paintballing
don't use the pepper she has a time in
her head she's like on Thursdays at
about 4 p.m. people come in and break in
with guns she's been beaten with a pipe
a couple times had to go for serious
psychological I just kind of be
legitimate PTSD not you know not a
feminist had a conservative show up at
their conference
like yours truly legitimate PTSD was a
lead-pipe we'll give you that one
exactly she has serious PTSD but she
talks about it so nonchalantly she's
like yeah at about 4 p.m. on these days
they come in and rob me right after we
interviewed her two days later she had
another armed robbery occur and she's
now moving out of country sold her
paintball shop but there you go can't do
much defending yourself with paintball
guns against literally having your place
broken into every single day it's though
I want to now I kind of want the pepper
paintball just for next time we go
paintball I shoot it right in your mass
could be like Michael Caine using the
anesthesia and his mask and the sight of
House Rules to fall asleep just
breathing it in your eyes watering less
than what the paintball was not very fun
I could have used a pepper paintball
strew these guys were wiping like it was
their job let me ask you this this
actually relates to um obviously been
talking this we just spoke with with
Nigel Farage about this the embassy in
Jerusalem it's this these completely
unrealistic standards not only
unrealistic completely on inconsistent
standards why do we not hear I know what
we don't hear that's sort of rhetorical
but isn't it remarkable that we don't
hear from the left here we're talking
about gross violations of human rights
let's remove the race equation portion
from the equation just violations of
human rights same thing we're talking
about Hamas who have it in their charter
the destruction of all Jews we're
talking about this when they're at the
wall planting mines go they go look
these babies were killed at the wall by
why there's the baby wars oh so
tone-deaf funbox they released a video
about the history of Palestine in and
Israel over it the fight over Jerusalem
they're showing footage of them throwing
junk at walls and exploding things and
with the sympathetic tone narrative
yeah raishin over top I'm like are you
watching the same footage you're showing
yeah I know I don't think there's it's
just for example if we were in the
States and we as Hamas started putting
rockets or nuclear arsenal look
obviously don't have nuclear weapons in
grade schools or in churches of course
they would be furious but we lose our
minds over clear back CS over clear
backpacks what why why do you think it
is that there is no talk of South Africa
because there's a comparison there from
the left where they say that Israel is
an apartheid state which it's not why do
you think there's you're the one who has
to make this film well there was plenty
of talk about South Africa during
apartheid era which obviously there were
gross human rights violations then
obviously they had laws that
specifically separated
some blacks completely hold Jim Crow
style stuff right but as soon as that
was taken away and the rainbow nation
narrative was sold to everyone Nelson
Mandela has created this nation where
it's going to be a perfect communist
progressive utopia left kept with that
narrative and as things started to
degrade the rand started to go down in
value crime started to go up because
they stopped enforcing the laws properly
and of course the South African
government has introduced quite
literally anti white laws of course the
left isn't going to talk about that
because that is not sympathetic to their
narrative it's it's frustrating how
obvious and predictable this just
repeated behavior from the left-wing
presses and the only there's been a few
pieces that have come out about me and
my documentary on the route and vice and
all of them are saying this myth this
myth of white genocide and I've never
even called it white genocide in my
documentary I've just said it's genuine
policies against whites they like to
blow up what I say and make it sound
like a crazy all right narrative which
it's not it's just purely facts that's
going on on the ground right so the only
coverage I've seen from this has been
smearing these poor farmers who are not
political people they're not right when
you're left-wing they're not nationalist
or anything there are people who have
literally had crimes committed against
them have family members tortured and
the left-wing press has no interest in
talking about it whatsoever they don't
want to humanize right I white people
they just did an article come out and
BuzzFeed that said how white women use
strategic tears to get what they want
what maybe some people are just sad and
it doesn't matter what skin color they
have maybe some people are just
oppressed and it's all that's all women
all women a couple of times have
probably used that at one point or
another Starbucks and you get addicted I
don't begrudge you you know you guys use
the tears we Muse Mel Gibson voicemails
this is what happens there are ways of
expressing ourselves but that is I'm
glad that you you touch it by the way
just to be clear South Africa has never
gotten it correct well then to apartheid
didn't get it correct and now it's not
correct they've never gotten their crap
together
I go Marxism and with Israel by the way
and I know you've gotten crap from the
alt-right so I'll talk with us because
of your you're just believing that
Israel has a right to exist so I think
the press is mistaken there I've gotten
the same kind of flack with Israel and
people can
a part that say go home all second if a
guy says hey let me in and that's what
why I won't kill you
and I don't let him in it's not because
he's blind because he said he wants to
kill me that's the apartheid Israel it's
not so much the melanin so much as the
loaded gun aimed at me through the
window at Lauren underscore seven
where's the best place for people to go
and make sure they don't miss this film
well my youtube channel
Lauren southern if you just look it up
if it isn't banned hopefully in the next
bit much like my UK and patreon
situation I will be up there for free
for everyone to see the point of this
film is for as many people to see it as
possible so share it on Facebook Twitter
wherever want to get the word out of
what the heck is going on there so at
the very least we don't make the mistake
again or maybe even we can prevent worse
crisis going on in South Africa in the
next bit yes the solution is send those
farmers Walters no more pepper paintball
guns we must go
Lauren southern dance us out
[Music]
the
I thought Hamas was a dip made from lots
of chickpeas it turns out it's a bunch
of dudes who thank Jews are a disease
they tried to break through the border
with more doors and shards of broken
glass but they got distracted when they
saw a goat's ass
oh sweet Palestine
oh oh oh oh sweet Palestine the Middle
East is always confusing to me
especially cuz the media lies but I
typically side with the people not
advocating genocide Hamas has an active
Twitter account and tells people to be a
hero and being a hero doesn't mean being
good it just means killing ben shapiro
palestinians just want people to accept
their very simple demands and those
demands are that every Jew and Christian
be murdered according to the Koran
oh sweet Palestine
oh oh oh oh sweet Palestine solo
[Music]
oh sweet Palestine
oh oh oh sweet Palestine
[Music]
[Music]
that's what I call the narcissistic
divert also known as a Greg Louganis and
bleeding 5/8 melody not in the
vocabulary whatever you probably don't
you're probably too young you probably
know the Greg Louganis was a diver in
the Olympics me did a backflip hit his
head in the board bled all over the pool
so crazy videos kinda like that one time
is gruesome that's a professional diver
at all no that was probably is why that
was really dumb and Phillips playing him
in the Greg Louganis story okay thank
you so much Nigel Farage john benjamin
and lauren southern very much appreciate
them being on the show next week we have
Ralph Macchio I know on Thursday and I
don't know we have an awesome Tuesday
and we have a on Monday
if this goes we have another change my
mind on Israel coming up here next
Tuesday we're not entirely sure because
we're waiting on a location but we'll
see we will keep you posted because
that's one of the lot of people
requested and also one for which many
people have asked that I be killed for
my Jumaane sure you at you the point
you're making earlier today actually I
went to the pitch which I thought was
was important interesting I haven't
think about the Denmark thing and you
were surprised by and I was surprised
about that they live at higher standard
of living standards of living and
percent higher us which is insane yeah
and I think what's funny about that we
talked about industrious the Dust
treasonous value your values and and
your your work ethic and your culture
plays such a huge role in the success of
huge anything a family a cult a country
economy your economy and the left can't
talk about that no because all cultures
are equal in value right discussion they
can't even have yeah we can't address it
it's a good point and it's to the
detriment of those couple of cultures
that could use some guidance right the
figure figure things out and fix them
stuff it isn't that ironic because you
know they talk about being progressive
but you can you can wipe out a
civilization by just allowing the
degradation of culture it just takes one
generation and nothing she funded that
actually I'm a little worried about that
I know everyone says this with their
generation right kids these days
that being said it's some point there is
a tipping point at some point there
isn't actual kids these days so you
always do kind of wonder if you're the
kids these days or your kids or the kids
these days and that was actually one of
them yes
and I was watching the killing of a you
saw the oj story yeah the true crime oh
the next one was a killing of Versace
right by the way Westworld sucks this
season well I people got mad it's
terrible loved season 1 west world is
please net ways after episode 4 I tapped
out every single shot was okay this
one's a host we get it's a robot please
move on back to the Ed Harris story
which is the only storyline that has any
loose ends to tie up anyway what's real
terrible but um I was watching the
killing of Versace I was watching it
with my wife and I don't never gave word
trigger warning but if you have kids
watching this is something just because
it is a show that obviously is not
suitable for children so take a minute
alright
for such [ __ ] when once Ricky Martin
takes a guy and throws him belly down on
the bed rips off his pants and starts
going to town was sitting there and I
turned to my wife and I said like oh
this is on FX right and out to the fact
that they just they don't happen to say
the F word it's a strong art I mean
there's a strong are I think it's on FX
right I don't know I could sounds right
it's it's on a network it's not just in
Netflix or Hulu show no no and
point-blank shots through the head you
know I remember seeing that for the
first time it being shocked as a kid I
think it was Saving Private Ryan
actually whenever I was allowed to see
it because it was a war film now you see
it gratuitously all over the place and I
know everyone complains about these
things later on Stan but it really is at
a point where it is it is we are
spiraling that drain really quickly and
I do have to I do worry listen I'm an
adult I can handle it and I don't think
that it inspires school shootings but I
do worry about my future kids if you
know my wife and I said we can only ever
watch anything in our bedroom away from
them first to make sure that it's okay
yeah not so bad life is subjective act
that we can have we have empirical data
on a lot of things that determine
success and in the well-being of a
culture Eve if it's full of Filth and
bad Westworld episodes ly questworld but
here's that it's not the yani Laurel
thing that we it's not just a matter of
opinion right how you see something like
that we have data we have information
it's not good to expose children to
these things young yeah it's not good to
expose children to things that that are
hyper sexualized hyper violent and
what's but as long as they don't say the
bad words yeah and that's the thing I
said well he didn't say the naughty word
so that's okay which always bother me
the hypocrites that you would get off
and that was the easiest thing for
Christians to check on the box
was I didn't say the naughty words like
one second what about your actions and
this makes sense why obviously the kill
but one thing I do like about the
Versace thing though we're kind of past
that that's a negative gay stereotype
right it was used to be willing Grace
once they got the domestic rights sound
it's like okay yeah Versace she's just a
bunch of gay people having sex getting
AIDS snorting coke and clubs because
that's what happened in Miami you wants
to lie about it no thank you I'm glad
that you guys made that because now we
can do the sketches we want to do so it
is well done it's a well done show I'm
not taking that away from it but I am
concerned when I watch these things I I
don't know the kind of world that my
kids are going to be raised with and I
think that everyone out there even if
you're a secularist I don't care what
religion you are you have to look at
something like gosh that's that's pretty
rough I don't know if I want this dancin
across the stream while my kids are
raised but it's about boards versus
actions with the left I highly doubt the
people from the far right are the ones
creating the killing of Versace
just in case you're one I don't think
they'd be allowed to make far right
mafia yes if they're if they pitched it
and they happen to have a voting record
of ever voting for a Republican senator
but no we're not allowing you an EP
credit on this there's no way we're
getting away with that one we work by
killing them people often denying blacks
to vote yes which is um and it's also it
also brought me this other point we kind
of were talking about this today so
talking about actions Owen Benjamin
Lauren southern Idol frosh what do they
all have in common guess in this show
really good lookin they're all
good-looking people
Nigel Faraj has that sort of rustic
charm I can see it I can say sometimes I
feel attract and and they guy is the
picture picture talk about being an
alpha in the room when the guy just
walks in the room it's like my body is
almost availing itself like what what is
happening this guy is just I'm not men
straight um but Lorne southern band from
England the UK Owen Benjamin banned from
Twitter banned from Pittsburgh
apparently made a bad place to be been
from LA Nigel Faraj obviously they tried
to ban him I don't know if it was Canada
they tried have tried to ban him and the
Metis persona non-grata on the media all
of these people have faced serious
severe discrimination if face serious
backlash have taken some serious hits
some dents for their views and by again
if we're talking about you think that
maybe these people are just profane
seeing that maybe they're just wrong
they're horrible human beings okay but
then I ask you is it worse than what
they express is that anything worse than
what you'd see on less world doing worse
than you would see in the killing of
Versace is anything
and you see Don Lemon dead Johnny math
is expressing that night in the news I
would say no Loren and Nigel certainly
aren't profane people Owen if you go see
a show and it's a Late Show and he's had
a couple blue moons he can go around the
bend a little bit but it's not
mean-spirited the point is again they
have the wrong opinion so it's weird an
age with culture where um first off
we've eliminated actions right you're at
your actions don't defy it's the words
that you use and that's one thing that's
why words keep being taken away we just
retroactively Lee had an old meme from
from Facebook did you see this removed
no there's two and a half years old some
it has the word [ __ ] in it hopefully
they don't comb through her video
catalogue this it it's now retro
actively a violation of her hate speech
laws and by the way wasn't it wasn't
even a Mt transgender at this primer it
was it was this harmless punchline but
it went back to like the first century
like this there were scenes of filtering
and going back and retroactively leap
Holdings would just explode you know
what if Facebook could just go back to
MySpace or Friendster yeah that's the
think of these these words along G but
you know what actions people's hearts
people's intents those don't change
that's pretty easy to see and there's
something I would say to people out
there if you have to determine what's
met what matters you like you said
cultures aren't all equal look at Japan
very industrious they do really well but
tiny plummeting Japanese bodies from
every skyscraper house like is suicide
rate Chinese Mary Hinton's Mary Poppins
battens nothing just cut out their whole
life Japan okay you got to get your life
in balance the work is good okay you
give us some cool technology but it's no
good to you if you're falling on a
window by the time you're 52 years old
so there is a difference you can look at
it statistically and there is a
difference in how people live their
lives the culture that you have with
your own within your own family before
you get to we talk this is a wife family
matters a nuclear family mom dad kids
right if you're a kid you want a daddy
you want a mommy in the house you want
them still together that is really you
said is far more important than putting
some more money into a local public
school that's failing anyway it
determines your level of success so
before we get to federal gun before we
get to steak and before we get the
municipal government it is governed by
yourself as for you and your house
social sons like that Kalama share you
think you just put one more dollar in
you're gonna get it right exactly
just one more dollar and think about
this for a second think about how you
live your life think what the difference
being your culture the culture between
your house and your neighbor's house the
culture between I don't know Owen
Benjamin Loren Nigel fraud just why do
you think it is that they are getting
knocked
if you think it's just because they're
asses if you think it's because they're
the wrong opinions and so they
rightfully should be banned from all the
places where other people who express
equally controversial opinions certainly
more hateful opinions are allowed if you
think it's just because the opinions
need to screw their opinion so you want
to remove them fine there's no
convincing you I'm not gonna fake
anymore like we need to find common
ground we don't have common ground
move along down the trail and go watch
something else but if you don't think
that they deserve to be banned simply
because of their opinions why do you
think they're getting bit why do you
think they're taking so many hits why do
you think a writer and editor in a
Pittsburgh paper doesn't want Owen to be
able to form their because of sold-out
shows why do you think the media hates
an idol for us why do you think Lauren
Southern's not allowed in the UK why do
you think Italy hates do you think it's
because they are always wrong or do you
think maybe it's because if you do
something important if you do something
worthwhile you're gonna have to take
some shots and that's one thing I know I
we talk about we've talked about this
before I did get an email this week from
someone you probably know who you are in
a college and this is nothing new asking
about the what do I do if I mean what do
I do if I'm in college and I don't want
I don't want my teacher to here's the
deal if you want to pass you want to get
a good grade keep it to yourself okay
but it's also nearly impossible to do in
2018 if you express an opinion that is
unpopular if you stand for something at
any point and I don't even care if you
stand for something you with which we
would agree you're gonna take some shots
and if you live a life where you don't
take any hits if you live a life where
you've never been banned if you live a
life where you've always been popular if
you live a life or everyone's always
said gee golly man he's a nice guy and
that's the first descripted they used
for you and the last descriptor nothing
wrong with being a nice guy but if it's
the only description that you're going
to get or woman ask yourself why that is
are you living a life of consequence
there's nothing wrong someone said I
manually measure it measured by how many
friends yes sometimes you're measured by
how many enemies you have as well I'll
tell you this I've had people in my life
we're talking about a culture there are
cultures they're easier we talk about
leisure cultures absolutely a lot of
Europe Greece hint hint
there are cultures that are harder but
you can't just have easy versus hard you
can't just have nice versus mean good
words versus bad naughty words as
opposed to actions you do have to is it
a fruitful culture and is your home as
for you and your house who what are you
serving is it a fruitful because if it's
a fruitful culture it's never going to
be easy
if you want to have kids who can be
raised in this world that we're a little
bit worried about and you want them to
end up not being sociopaths guess what
they're gonna have to take some licks
and so are you if you wanna be
successful if you wanna be recognized
for anything more than being milquetoast
a guy who can get along with at a party
or a girl you're gonna have to take some
shots and if you aren't there's a strong
chance if all you're doing by the way is
fight in the whole world at every single
point there look the chance you're in oh
absolutely but if you never find
yourself in controversy if you never
find yourself getting some bumps and
bruises along the way there's a strong
chance that you might be living a life
that is completely inconsequential and
that's no way to be so so the guy who
wrote to me about college you gotta make
it you want to pass keep it to yourself
but at some point you have to make a
decision you ever getting hit it mean it
means you're out there with the puck it
means you're out there taking some risks
and that's okay that's not always a bad
thing we'll talk to you next weeks being
getting hit Ralph Macchio he'll be there
[Music]